hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in the
final round around 14 of the 2016
canada's tournament winner of this
tournament does go on to face magnus
carlsen in november for the world
championship now our competitors today
just happen to be tied for 1st not
because they are tied for versus why
they're playing today was predetermined
before the tournament that they would
play las around just for the chess fans
it just so happens that they are number
one and it's hide for first so sorry to
get outa yakkin playing the white pieces
from russia his opponent
Fabiana Caruana from the united states
playing the black pieces if you're not
super familiar with the situation this
year non tied today against Peters
Fiedler and so with that certainty a cow
to Yakima
can to win the tournament with either a
win or a draw so he just has to draw and
he wins Fabiana Caruana playing the
black pieces he's got a tough road ahead
but he's gonna bring everything he can
but he needs to win this match to be the
champion so we'll go ahead and get into
it saturday starts out with pawn to e4
and then pawn c5 and we've been seeing a
lot of the right Lopez getting into the
Berlin defense Robby hammock Rwanda
sides okay I got to go with the sharpest
defense a tie gets me nowhere I have to
win this so the Sicilian offense is how
he responds that f3 knight c6 pawn at d4
after the exchange on board Knight f6
Knight c3 pawn to d6 so a little bit
different than some of the more common
moves from black pawn to e6 pretty
common pawn to a6 pretty common as well
but trying something a little bit
different pawn to d6 Bishop to g5
getting outside the pawn chain pond e6
Queen to d2 pawn a six and then castle
on the Queen side so it looks like
certainly a caddy yakun is playing a
pretty aggressive opening castling on
the Queen side getting ready to attack
on the Kings side
Fabiano has a few different options it's
gonna be pretty difficult for him to go
ahead and castle on the Queen side
Sicilian defense after you kind of lose
your pawn on the C file it does get a
little tough so he could
to develop Bishop to e7 castle on the
Kings side right away or he could
completely abandon that start to push
immediately on the Kings side and just
not even worried about his king safety
block continues with Bishop to d7 upon
to f4 so immediately starting to attack
on the King side pawn h6 forcing the
Bishop back and then pawn be 5 so
Fabiano starts to attack on the Queen
side Bishop takes on f6
and then pawn captures on f6 and this is
one of those moves where if you kind of
look at it you can see Fabiano's
approach he is not gonna do the common
safe my opponent knows exactly what I'm
gonna do which would be Queen to f6 this
is definitely the most common
straightforward path pawn takes on f6 is
pretty much saying that he may not
castle on the Kings side now I could
still castle on the Queen side he's not
gonna have a lot of protection in front
of his King but if he wants to swing his
aah rook over to the King side of the
board he does have that option but
Fabiano knows that he's got a tough path
ahead of him so he's going to try to put
his opponent in his many awkward
situations as possible hoping that
Sergei just takes a lot of time in every
position and essentially gets to a point
where he doesn't have a lot of time
makes a mistake in in Fabiano can take
over so from here pawn to f5 Queen down
here b6 we do see an exchange on board
so now kind of all the pawns have gone
past the seventh rank and the King
hasn't moved so hey there's not a lot of
protection in front of this King so
Sergei eventually if he can get behind
enemy lines you can have a strong attack
on Fabiano's King Fabiano on the other
hand he can just really start to push
and put a lot of pressure on his
opponent he's got three central pawns he
can put his King over here to f7
even a seven potentially use this really
as protection and then swing these rooks
over to c8 control that semi-open file
to g8 control everything coming from the
sides and then just kind of overwhelm
his opponent now the knight takes on a
c6
the Queen recaptures and then Bishop
here to d3 just trying to hold on to
this isolated pawn here on e4 now on
black side that you know Fabiano has his
own isolated pawn here on h6 so Sergei
if he wants to we can attack this at
some point but Fabiana is going to be
looking to start to attack this pawn
here on e4
Fabiana continues with pawn to h5 King
to be one protecting the a2 upon pawn to
b4 forcing the knight to move knights
back here e to I mean Queen at c5 just
pushing up miss here a little bit
controlling the center of the board as
much as possible
rook over here f1 attacking the pawn on
f6 two ways to kind of come back this
one is just immediately defend this the
other one is to just play kind of it in
between move this [ __ ] parent h6
attacking the Queen the Queen comes back
here to e1 and then pawn to a 5 and I
thought this was pretty interesting to
play a5 and not really try to protect
the square here on f6 and then we see
pawn to b3 another interesting move I
thought for sure I still think it's
probably best for white to just take
here on f6 Queen e5 rooked back here to
f3 Bishop g7 I I think this is fine
White is up mature on board he can start
to put a lot of pressure on the pawn on
e4 Bishop to c6 eventually he can
overwhelm him but white right now is up
material on board I think he can
definitely hold on to it just defend the
center of the board as much as possible
but I decided to not take that instead
kind of play more of the defensive move
pawn to b3 a rook g8 is we talked about
controlling the semi open file up on g3
kind of stopping that king e7 just
adding some protection on these pawns so
the minor pieces the Queen they don't
have to worry about protecting that a
bishop here to see for attacking the
square here on e6 just more central
square if the pawn here on d5 wants to
come there just adds another layer of
protection to start to defend that and
then Bishop to e3 and this is a move I
really don't like from from Fabiano
because you have Sarah go over here he's
fine just exchanging all
tear off the board a drawl for him is a
win he doesn't even need to do anything
too crazy he's trying not to do anything
too crazy once the the bishop comes down
here we have Knight to f4 and all of a
sudden this sort of just stops this
Bishop the bishops probably going to
fall Bishop takes all of a sudden the
pond recaptures more material that
Fabiano can't use to attack his opponent
put them in separate positions so kind
of surprised to see Bishop to e3 even
more surprised to see rook to f3 for
those who actually kind of watch the
stream with the grandmasters giving
their commentary they all thought Knight
f3 was gonna be pretty automatic but
Sergei seems to be looking at these
moves for quite a long time which is
what Fabiana wants he wants a lot of
time to be spent on every single move
and it seemed like 3 to 5 minutes every
single move which overtime really
definitely chips away you get two hours
for the first 40 moves and then after
that you do get an additional hour from
here the risks gonna come to a g4 and
then Queen to f1 just adding another
layer of protection it's start to attack
this pawn here on f6 and then a rook
over here f8 protecting the pawn a
little bit more now we see Knight to f4
and Bishop is somewhat forced to go
ahead and take that we do see in
exchange and then pawn to a4 and then
pawn takes on a4 and then after the
Bishop takes then Queen here to d3 so
white has done a good job of starting to
get summits here off the board and now
he looks to really control this D file
in the center of the board Bishop back
here to c6 attacking the isolated pawn
that's really all Fabiano has going for
him right now it's attacking that
isolated pawn bishop back here to b3 a
nice outpost that it's gonna be tough
for Fabiana to really get this off the
board a rook here to a g5 pawn to e5
which is another interesting move it
gives up a pawn on board now white can
kind of shift his focus to start to
attack this now I
lady pond on the B file Fabiano can
either try to protect this pawn here or
completely avoid it and try to attack
over here on the kingside but right now
Fabiano all of a sudden he's winning
this is a position he's up upon the
material he's controlling the stern of
the board so things right now look very
bright for Fabiano and both sides have
about 20-25 minutes left in the game so
they don't have a ton of time to be
thinking about all their moves now white
plays a rook to a c4 attacking the Queen
and then rook to d5 and I thought this
was pretty interesting from Fabiano he
looks like he's going to allow his
opponent to exchange off board and I was
kind of surprised we didn't see it we
see Queen here to e2 what we could have
easily seen rook takes the rook takes
here on d3 we see an exchange on board
pawn up here to d4 that takes the rook
takes here I think you may have looked
at it and said I hate my opponent is up
upon a material I need to keep as much
material as I can to maybe get a
different better position on board
because he looked at this and maybe
calculated and said I think I'll lose in
this position I can't gain that that
pond back potentially so in this
position he just didn't really like it
you're gonna see the rook swing over
here to b8 protecting that isolated pawn
so as we do come back on board the Queen
is gonna come to e2 now the black king
our black queen codes back to b6 now
rook over here to h4 starting to attack
the isolated pawn here on h5 also a
discovered attack with a bishop
attacking the rook here on d5 as you can
imagine the the rook almost has to move
it still wants to maintain control of
the h5 squared and attack the Queen the
Queen comes back here to d3 just adding
pressure on this D foul right here and
then Bishop to g2 this was another
interesting move that a lot of the
commentators they did not think they
would see pawn to d5 makes a lot of
sense it kind of blocks a lot of this
pressure from this LightSquared bishop
you know this square right here is being
protected by the bishop and the rook
right here so it's gonna be tough for a
lot of crazy shenanigans all in all this
is pretty good and now Fabiana was
getting pretty bold he said I'm gonna go
ahead and play my bishop down here to g2
then he wants to play d5 and then bring
his bishop back here to e4 a much better
outpost move for his Bishop still
controlling this long diagonal but
definitely a a pretty optimistic view of
kind of how this would go a rook back
here to d4 so not nearly going to be as
strong now to bring his bishop back but
pawn to d5 as we talked about Queen here
to d2 and then rook to e4 and this is
kind of a crazy move if you if you think
about it and this is where he kind of
puts his opponent to the test the entire
tournament hinges on this one move
certainty a karyakin it has about 14
minutes left on the clock in this
position as he looked at it it's very
tough to find the best move now the best
move on board is actually rook takes on
d5 sacrificing the rook after the pawn
takes here on d5 for the Queen to come
up here to d5 threatening mates with
Queen to d7 putting a lot of pressure on
his opponents there's not a lot of great
squares for black to defend this to be
honest we can have rook to d4 and just
try to give some of that material back
Queen takes on d4 the Queen takes rook
takes up here and then we're over here
to be a trying to hold down this
material all of a sudden black is down
upon and he's for the most part trying
to hold on to a pawn or a draw in this
position but still pretty tough but if
we come back after rook here T for any
other move from white but beyond rook
takes on d5 it pretty much loses it's
gonna be super tough for whites really
hold on just adding too much pressure on
board in the end Sergei thought for
about
five minutes and he did find the move
rook takes on d5 a very very strong move
and plays continues as we talked about
pawn takes on d5 we now don't see rook
to a d4 instead we see a queen to c7
just trying to hold on does not want to
get checkmated and then Queen to f5 and
this is move that Fabiana said that he
didn't really calculate the entire line
he didn't see Queen to f5 you know he
may have been trying to calculate Queen
to h5 even if he didn't calculate Queen
to f5 it's still a very very much losing
position it's gonna be tough for Fabiana
to kind of hold on to this rook to f7
Bishop takes on f7 you know there's no
way to really stop the attack right here
a Queen to e5 rook up here d7 King f8
rook to d8 and in this position Fabiano
resigned as far as how it could continue
you know you may say hey you could just
take here on f7 but this is still going
to be hold are tough to hold on to we
have Queen here to h7 the King is pretty
much forced to come here to e6 and then
Queen to d7 would be checkmate no other
moves are good as well they all end in
mate so Fabiano gave his best effort I
applaud him for finding the craziest
lines he could possibly find in this
Sicilian defense but all in all serving
a county yakun he fended him off played
extremely well and not only got the the
draw but got the win
so serve gave karyakin winner of the
2016 Canada's tournament he will
represent Russia and face Magnus Carlsen
in November for the world championship
so we definitely have some youngsters I
know in the previous rounds we've had
Magnus Carlsen first fishing on so I
think it'll be exciting match they've
played almost 20 matches against each
other
Sergei ds-11 Magnus Carlsen is one three
and then they've drawn about 15 just
kind of give you some historical
reference on how they
done against each other all in all I
think it's gonna be great both players
are playing extremely well my guess is
magnus carlsen win I just think he's
that strong but I am extremely excited
for November to see these players face
off hopefully you enjoyed this
tournament a lot of back and forth that
the leaderboard just got so congested at
the top it was anyone's game for a long
time so it's exciting to kind of see
everyday you know people going from 1st
to 3rd
tied for 1st then it all comes down to
the last match and we got to see two
players actually play for the title so
thanks for watching all the videos of
the coverage and I will see y'all in the
next one and definitely in November will
be having coverage of every round of the
World Championship so thank you guys and
I'll see you later